I think the only real news here today is
your graduation from this great
University
first of all congratulations I'm
impressed that your achievements have
attracted so much media attention as
well they should I'm so happy to be here
to share this important day my own
college graduation is still a thrilling
memory in fact I actually had breakfast
this morning with one of my college
classmates Barclay Reeves who's one of
the very proud parents of a graduate
sitting out here today and one of my
favorite family photos is of my busting
with pride father at Harvard a college
dropout he never got to wear his own cap
and gown so he crams his six-foot self
into mine he looks silly but radiant I
hope all of you in the class of 2014 are
lucky enough to have at least one parent
or someone who helped raise you here
today a shout-out to all the parents
grandparents and others in the audience
my own children our recent college grads
so I know how full your hearts are today
because your kids have worked so hard
and achieved so much president Hatch
suggested that I speak to you today
about resilience and I'm gonna take his
wise counsel but I'm not quite finished
with the parents part very early last
Thursday my sister called me she said I
know dad would be as proud of you today
as the day you became executive editor
of the New York Times I've been fired
the previous day so I knew what she was
trying to say it meant more to our
Father to see us deal with a setback and
try to bounce back than to watch how we
handled our successes so what you are
made of he would say graduating from
Wake Forest means all of you have
experienced success already and some of
you and now I'm talking to anyone who's
been dumped you bet not gotten the job
you really wanted or receive those
horrible rejection letters from grad
school you know the sting of losing
we're not getting something you badly
want when that happens show what you're
made of I was in China recently and as
some of you know the New York Times
website has been blocked by censors
there for more than a year that means in
China citizens cannot read the most
authoritative coverage of their country
and every time I reflexively tried to
open the Times website I got the message
Safari cannot open the page which made
me become more and more furious while I
was in Beijing one of our Chinese
journalists Pak Patrick Zhou was
detained for hours by authorities the
government meant to scare and intimidate
him why was he detained simply because
he worked as a truthful journalist so
what did he do he came right back to
work and quietly got on with things I
did what I believed and that makes me
fearless Patrick told me after his
ordeal you know New York Times Journal
Swiss their lives frequently to bring
you the best news report in the world
that's why it is such an important and
irreplaceable institution and it was the
honor of my life to lead the newsroom a
couple of students who I was talking to
last night after I arrived they know
that I have some tattoos and one of them
asked me are you gonna get that x Qi
that you have tattooed on your back were
moved not a chance
I fixed a little challenge of my own not
long ago I got run over and almost
killed by a truck in Times Square
you may begin to call me calamity Jill
but stay with me here and with the
seventh anniversary of that accident
approaching I wrote an article about the
risk to pedestrians with three-times
colleagues who had also been struck and
her we mentioned a nine-year-old boy in
the top of our story who had been hit
and killed by a cab early in the year a
few days after the story was published I
got an email from Dana Lerner
it began thank you for the article you
wrote in last Sunday's Times the boy you
mentioned is my son Hooper stock
I met with Jay in the last Thursday you
know and Cooper was just killed in
January but Dana her husband and others
are already working on a new law to make
the streets safer she is taking an
unimaginable loss and already trying to
do something constructive we human
beings are a lot more resilient than we
often realize resilient and persevering
and there are so many examples of this
for me professionally three heroes are
nan Robertson a groundbreaking reporter
of the New York Times and Katherine
Graham the publisher of The Washington
Post which broke the Watergate story
they both face discrimination and a much
tougher more male-dominated newspaper
industry and they went on to win
Pulitzer Prizes my colleague Jim Rison
who is standing up against an unfair
Washington leak investigation is another
hero I I co-authored a book about Anita
Hill who testified about sexual
harassment before an all-white all-male
Senate Judiciary Committee in the 1990s
the Senators portrayed her as being as
one of heard attack detractors so
delicately put it a little bit nutty and
a little bit [ __ ] she turned that
potential humiliation into a great
career teaching at Brandeis University
and writing books that tell truth to
power Anita was one of the many people
who wrote me last week to say they are
proud of me those messages are so
appreciative some of you have faced
danger or even a soul scorching loss but
most of you haven't and leaving the
protective cocoon of school for the
working world must seem scary you will
probably have a dozen different jobs try
all different things
sure losing a job you love hurts but the
work I revere journalism that holds
powerful institutions and people
accountable is what makes our democracy
so resilient this is the work I will
remain very much a part of my only
reluctance in showing up today was that
the small media circus following me
would detract attention away from you
the fabulous class of 2014
what total knockouts you are
what's what's next for me I don't know
so Amon exactly the same boat as many
unlike you I'm a little scared but also
excited you know I don't really think
coach man and could find it's much use
for me but right after this speech I've
booked a private session with Andy Chan
whose career counseling operation is a
model for universities around the world
when I was leaving my office for the
last time I grabbed a book off myself
Robert Frost speaking on campus in
closing I'm going to leave you with some
wisdom from the Colby College
commencement speech the great poet gave
in 1956 he described life after
graduating as pieces of knitting to go
on with what he meant was that life is
always unfinished business like the bit
submitting women used to carry around
with them to be picked up at different
intervals and for those of you who have
never met think of it at the Kin to your
tumblr something you can pick up from
time to time and change my mother was a
great knitter and she made some really
magnificent things but she also made a
few itchy frankly hideous sweaters from
heaven she left some things unfinished
so today you gorgeous brilliant people
get on with your knit